so bezeichnen jetzt bei halloween
erzähle ich kann jetzt als möglicher
erzählungen weiß und zwar fast gar
nichts so warum kommt ihr der hund alter
verpiss dich doch hallöchen löchern
löchern meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
lost ich hab's ja nun alter halt die
klappe du scheiße und nein du bist der
geldkarte also was ich heute mache ist
etwas klein bisschen anderes wir gehen
das mal ganz kurz kennen letztes mal war
ja nachts und zwar probiere ich heute
etwas aus und zwar ist es dieses
facebook themen gespräche dings was mir
sehr oft und sehr viel und sehr oft und
sehr viel und so weiter in die
kommentare geschrieben wurde und zwar
meinten da immer wieder leute nok mach
mal hier bei facebook nebenbei so live
stream und live ticker und so dass wir
diese fragen stellen können weil ich
habe nämlich auch mal gefragt was alles
mit zu diesem plan sag ich mal gehört
warum ihr eigentlich meine videos guckt
da haben dann ganz viele leute wirklich
geschrieben
ja weil du immer themen behandelt die
wirklich auch leute interessieren und
nicht so einen quatsch wie berichtet man
px quadrat aus mit dem und dem
schwachsinn wie das andere let's play
offs ok cool vielleicht kann ich davon
einmal ein bisschen mehr machen das
heißt schreibt mir einfach mal themen
hier bei facebook im post erstellt warte
ich jetzt mal kurz vor
also jetzt hab ich geschrieben von fünf
minuten ok ich nehme meine folge lust
auf also wer fragen oder themen hat
kamen mir die hier schreiben unter den
post smiley post macht der aufnahme
wieder gelöscht sei sich jetzt ganz auf
einem bildschirm drücke steuerung er
dann wird das aktualisiert und an sich
die neuen kommentare wenn irgend eine
möglichkeit ist dass sich das
automatische aktualisiert bitte einfach
in die kommentare schreiben
dann geb und zwar wurden wir da wirklich
viele dinge vorgeschlagen weil ich mal
quatschen könnte uns einige dinge
worüber ich damals schon dachte dass der
über quatschen kann aber irgendwie die
teile die themen wieder verdrängt habe
oder so keine ahnung
na ja also ich würde sagen das eisen da
lagen egal
ich würde sagen wir fangen direkt mal an
und zwar möchte ich gerne erstmal über
ein thema reden was mich wenn man
fleisch zurück was nicht mich
beschäftigt sondern was ist eigentlich
schon von allen seiten ja bis 4 3 d
was mich wirklich schon seit längerer
zeit beschäftigt und zwar ist es die
zeit für youtube das hat gar nicht wo
wir stehen geblieben würden könnte man
einfach in die montafoner gegen also
viele leute meinen immer immer wieder
von crafter andere youtuber die machen
vier videos sonntag was machst du machst
nur 1 oder höchstens mal 2 also erstmal
es gibt ja diese schöne sprichwort
qualität und quantität also ist kein
sprichwort sondern es gibt ja dieses ich
sag mal dass man das halt so nennt so
qualität vor quantität also so ist es
bei mir ich mache auf jeden fall erstmal
noch leitern und das nehme ich mir sehr
sehr zu herzen
es gibt youtuber die bringen wirklich
jeden tag also letzt player die bringen
täglich fünf sechs videos raus ersetzt
ich habe eigentlich gar kein beispiel
aber es gibt halt welche
hundertprozentig auch amerika
panamericana amerikaner amerikaner
amerikaner mehrere keine ahnung gut
drauf die bringt halt ziemlich viele
videos raus aber dann halt mit gar
keiner bearbeitung das heißt keine
anmerkungen datei ist kein intro das
heißt keine hintergrundmusik man man
sieht richtig einfach oder man hört oder
sieht es keine ahnung dass diese firmen
oder hingesetzt haben aufgenommen haben
und ich mache mir gedanken bei jedem
video wie kann ich zu bearbeiten was für
musik könnte ich bei welcher stelle
nehmen und so weiter also wirklich schon
so ein paar mehr sachen da brauche ich
noch steine für fällt mir grad auf und
das nicht einmal schätzen einige von
euch nicht ich will nicht wieder alle
von euch also ich hab ich mache das
eigentlich immer wirklich so dass ich
sage ja es hat da immer weil das wäre
wieder auf euch alle bezogen und
das finde ich nicht so gut wenn man das
auf alle bezieht weil naja ihr wisst
schon
wenn man das auf alle bezieht es gibt
immer leute die nicht so denken na ja
egal
einige von euch meinen echt dass das
total scheiße sei dass ich mittlerweile
echt nur täglich also zurzeit muss ich
echt sagen täglich nur ein video
rausbringen rausbringen kann alle die
mit bei facebook folgen was ich wirklich
nur empfehlen kann nicht weil ich da
irgendwie ganz viele follower haben will
das bringt mir überhaupt nix da sind
ganz viele follower stehen das dann
einfach nur eine zahl halt aber was ich
sagen kann ist dass ich mal ganz kurz
überlegen muss und zwar wird man wenn
die monster darunter fallen entfallen
die hier drauf doch mache ich hier
wieder an der kammer noch ein bisschen
runter gehen danke und zwar muss ich
sagen ich hab echt immer informiert wenn
ihr bei mir bei facebook seite und
braucht solche fragen auch gar nicht
stellen also einige von euch und zwar
habe ich dort auch letztens gepostet bei
facebook jo ich habe jetzt erst mal
klausurphase klausurphase heißt viele
von euch sind jahr zwölf ist der
durchschnitt von männer von hinten also
das alter und die wissen wahrscheinlich
nicht was klausurphase ist das ist das
hat man in einem schuljahr
beziehungsweise in einem schulhalbjahr
hat man das zweimal da hat man eine
klausurphase da schreibt man in zwei
drei wochen alle klausur fächer die man
wirklich schriftlich hat bei mir sind
das sechs fächer das sind deutsch und
englisch lkw's also da schreibt man
wirklich drei stunden lang klausur also
wir noch zurzeit bei insight vier
stunden letzten klasse also einer 12 ich
habe deutsch englisch latein mathe sowie
und was da schon so wie ich hab so das
war's schon
ja egal ich hab 5 und da habe ich davon
diese fünf klausuren habe ich in der
letzten woche ersetzt in der letzten
woche die jetzt jetzt er hatte also
heute samstag er heute samstag waren
wieviel videos habe ich da gemacht also
da hat da waren drei klausuren auf jeden
fall und die klausuren waren am dienstag
donnerstag und freitag und da ist
natürlich klar dass ich dann am montag
und am sonntag für die klausur am
dienstag gelernt habe
dann am dienstag für die klausur am
dienstag/mittwoch für die klausur am
donnerstag und am donnerstag hatte ich
dann nur zeit für die klausur am freitag
also ich hatte echt sehr sehr wenig zeit
das habe ich aber eigentlich ganz gut
gemacht finde ich jetzt ohne dich
irgendwie selbst zu loben aber ich finde
das habe ich doch ganz gut gemacht und
weiblich vorher schon alles aufgenommen
wird das dann im voraus hochgeladen
deswegen kam täglich nur ein video
das heißt dass er trotzdem videos hat
obwohl ich eigentlich nie in youtube war
an der zeit
und das hat eigentlich ganz gut geklappt
hat man kann ich nicht theoretisch geht
das eigentlich noch hier und das geht
nicht
schade ich muss mich mal ganz kurz
überlegen wie weit geht natalie
eigentlich ich mache das jetzt erstmal
auf jeder seite hier so bissig hier ist
oder ich finde eigentlich das was ganz
gut geplant wurde mit jedem tag ein
video und deswegen kommen einfach nicht
so viele videos zur zeit aber die
klausurphase ist jetzt ich schreibe
jetzt noch eine klausur nächste woche
mittwoch
und danach ist erstmal langes wochenende
also da wird auf jeden fall werde ich
das feiern gehen und auch nicht soviel
ihren youtube rocken aber ich denke das
eine oder andere kann man da schon mal
aufnehmen
übrigens jetzt auch das wasteland zu
ende das heißt wenn ich jetzt auch was
neues plan ich habe schon was im
hinterkopf geplant also für mich alleine
so ein projekt dass racing kam war ich
super gut an
wo es aber mal zu sagen habe ich auch am
ende von vom letzten video da noch mal
geschrieben und dann von anmerkungen
deswegen werde ich so etwas in die
richtung machen
jetzt sehen was da kommt auf jeden fall
mache ich das erst mal alleine und ja so
und nun will ich sagen kommt zu euren
themen achso noch eine sache und zwar
habe ich bei twitter gepostet dass ich
für happy jetzt eine super idee ab da
kam alle an hey du machst face squaw
geil
nur weil ihr das sagt stimmt das nicht
also manche leute haben es echt geglaubt
und haben dann oft unter geschrieben
crafter macht ihr facetime und so nur
weil das eine art unter geschrieben hat
das stimmt nicht ich mache nicht mit
face kenn ich habe auf meinem zweikanal
mal ein video gemacht warum ich mich
nicht zeige und dazu stehe ich
mittlerweile auch immer noch und ja mehr
bräuchte dazu eingehen ich sagen ich
meine die idee werde ich erst mal nicht
verraten ihr werdet schon sehen was dann
kommt aber ich denke eigentlich dass
euch gefallen wird und ich weiß auch gar
nicht ob ich höre ich hier eigentlich
den bc sein muss
ich bin mal kurz mal da hinten welcher
höhe das war jetzt kommt der super job
klasse und es verbittert war es
eigentlich erst mal und jetzt kommt eure
themen und zwar habe ich das eher
gepostet niklas schmitz ich lese einfach
mein name mit mit nachname vorname
vorname nachname vor weil wenn die leute
das eh schon bei facebook post mit ihrem
namen und jeder das sehen kann dann kann
ich das auch so erwähnen also dass damit
braucht jetzt auch gar nicht meckern das
ist legal sage ich mal so ach so ich
wollte gucken aber das ist jetzt blöd
wenn ich jetzt hier gucken welche höre
ich bin weil ich dann den ski zeige dann
guck ich nicht wie ich jetzt nicht ich
glaube das müsste doch schon ungefähr
weit genug sein wird ich habe mich hier
gleich ich gehe gleich wieder auf der
einen seite habe ich dann auf der
anderen wieder runter so niclas schmidt
sagt dortmund gegen real ist natürlich
ein thema was ihr an die fußballfreunde
von euch geht das war natürlich ein
geiles spiel
das müsste ich eigentlich immer noch vor
allem also einer szene als ich habe echt
so gedacht abend so das war das spiel
war am dienstag oder mittwoch vulkan
ich glaube ich weiß gar nicht mehr wann
das spiel war 100 ungefähr rottweiler
twittwoch mittwoch oder donnerstag war
es auf jeden fall
naja jedenfalls ist mir dort wirklich
aufgefallen bzw
das war so der einzige tag wo ich dann
nicht lernen musste ich weiß gar nicht
ob ich überhaupt noch richtig bin ich
kann einfach gucken wie viel ich hier
ach so so wartet manchmal ganz kurz
konzentrieren
wie weit ist da ungefähr 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
so da bin ich gerade auf 8 steinen
runter ich muss man jetzt kurz hier
vorne kommt nach quatsch wieder weiter
wer die stadt ab 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
ältere sohn kleinstück und zwar dort und
hatte gegen real gespielt in der
champions league zeitgleich mit schalke
gegen essen und hätte eigentlich wenn
ich getippt hätte bei tipico oder so das
machen wir manchmal ein bisschen mehr
sein ich mache das nicht das machen
andere bei mir aus der stufe und halt
jetzt eher weniger von aber wenn der
andere getippt hätte nicht ein kumpel
gesprochen der es mag er hätte auf
arsenal getippt doch real madrid und
beides nicht eingetreten war einerseits
schalke und dortmund gewonnen haben
dortmund hat tatsächlich gegen real
madrid gewonnen und das hat mich so was
von gewundert da die tat wirklich
hingekriegt haben weil real madrid alle
die ein bisschen ahnung vom fußball
haben wissen real madrid ist nicht so
das schlechteste team und ich weiß auch
dass ich mich gerade hier sowas von
ich habe gerade überhaupt keine ahnung
wo ich mich ort um chance auch ein
kleines stück weit daneben
im moment dann musste ich jetzt da unten
wo sein bitte ich hoffe einfach dass ich
jetzt mal im boot da da da bin ich hallo
hallo leute ich hab ich den kleinen
gefunden also real madrid ist somit das
beste einzelspieler team in europa
natürlich legen als fußballexperten
ankommen und sagen hey dritte volker
keller voll blöd aber man muss sagen die
haben den größten gesamtwert glaube ich
an spielern oder ist das barcelona ich
weiß es gar nicht auf jeden fall sind
sie mit eines der besten teams weltweit
muss man einfach so sagen und alle also
ich glaub auch bei tipico gab es eine
wette alle die ein bisschen ahnung von
wetten dass ungefähr was sie erzählt
klopp dortmund hatte eine fehlerquote
obwohl sie zu hause gespielt haben oder
so oder berichte ich mich wenn ihr
selber am besten seite und das irgendwie
besser wird oder so treffen da kann ich
als theoretisch wieder abbauen
und das war echt krass weil wenn man
darauf dort mit wirklich gesetzt hätte
ein euro hätte man gesetzt man für ihre
bekommen als jetzt erst mal wenig an
sophie euro aber ich meine fehlerquote
stelle bei 600 euro oder kriegt ihr 400
oder was er auch war war bei dem
dingsbums hier weil es keine mir wieder
runter bauen war bei marie ist das noch
gleich
deutschland gegen schweden das war auch
witzig da hat deutschland ja 4 0 geführt
und dann in den letzten 30 minuten
schießt schweden noch vier tore und es
steht am ende 44 also unentschieden
schweden hatte zum zeitpunkt der 60
minute eine quote von 20 30
das heißt eine neue gesetz hätte dir 30
euro gewonnen und das haben sogar welche
gemacht die haben da dann locker 10 euro
gesetzt und haben danach hängen die 300
400 euro gewonnen und haben dann an das
bild an die seite der deutschen
nationalmannschaft bei facebook gepostet
auf euch jetzt einfach verlassen damit
seinem zettel weil dann wirklich sein
kupon da hat und dann lediglich 1000
euro wandert oder so 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 18 19 20 12 10 23 10 15 79 32 31 ich
gucke mal ganz gut ich bin 12 34 51 wie
soll ich das nicht machen hatte ich
mache einfach so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 12 steine runter bauen und da ich da
schon zweite ich bin heißt dass noch 10
8 okay ja also es ist echt krass was ihr
in letzter zeit für spieler ab laufen
oder allgemein im fußball weil ja auch
bayern münchen ungeschlagen in der
bundesliga mit mit 87 glaube ich
mittlerweile schon das ist echt krass
das gab es bisher noch nie acht siege
hintereinander also nicht hintereinander
sondern
acht siege allgemein am anfang der
saison also wenn sie es wirklich
ungeschlagen schaffen was eigentlich gar
nicht sein kann weiß auch noch gegen
schalke gegen dortmund alle möglichen
leute da spielen wenn sie das wirklich
schaffen ungeschlagen du da mache ich in
real life video wie ich nacktbaden
schaffen sie eh nicht da kann man nicht
schaffen
irgendwie werde ich dann schon dafür
sorgen ein also wenn sie dann wirklich
schaffen das wäre schon echt hammer
hammer geil
naja gut sodass das erste thema wird 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 okay das war das
erste thema von niklas schmitz
zweites thema wie kamst du zum drehen
das sind so fragen die mich 1000 mal
beantworte ich meine ich hatte einfach
langweilig osterferien mal irgendwann
gedacht kommt erst mal ein bisschen was
los war dann allerdings blüht dann habe
ich wieder allein gelassen habe ich mit
diesem kontrast kanal neuen kanal
gemacht und da ging es dann halt los wo
dann wirklich so cool vorbei und da ging
es dann richtig ab mit abonnenten also
da was dann wirklich so dass die leute
das echt cool fand was ich gemacht habe
und ja sagt so kam ich halt zum drehen
spielst du häufig auf öffentlichen
servern und wenn ja hast du das auch
irgendein extra account nun ganz einfach
eigentlich also ich spiele minecraft
wenn ich aufnehme ja okay wenn ich
aufnehme spiele ich aber es ist
irgendwie klar dass ich es spielen aber
wenn ich nicht aufnehmen spiel minecraft
eigentlich ein bisschen weil ich alle
eigentlich wenn ich irgendwie mal zeit
habe oder so möchte ich dir nicht fürs
zocken investieren oder in das zocken
investieren sondern entweder dass ich
dann videos mache eine falsche höhe
entweder das sich videos mache oder dass
ich sag mal planung lernen oder inga
sinnvolles machen weil zocken an sich
mittlerweile finde ich einfach gar keine
zeit mehr für weil in meiner jetzigen
zeit in der schule muss man echt eine
menge lernen damit man dann irgendwie
hängen bleibt hängen bleibe ich hab ich
überhaupt keinen bock nochmal sonja zu
wiederholen
und naja single oder nicht ist eine
frage die mich einfach nicht beantworten
gang namens teil von alexei baxi alexy
becks die kenne ich gern als teil auch
aber ich kenne ich ganz teil von alexei
vecsey wie kamst auf den namen
contractor fragt die no better rewitz wo
der server schon tausend mal gesagt
konnten also kräfte wegen minecraft
crafter und kommen einfach während dem
spiel kommenden konnte was ich damals
noch ein bisschen gespielt habe klingt
komisch ist aber so was auch teilweise
mir leute sagen konnten ist französisch
und heißt arschloch arschloch crafter
ich beleidige sie dadurch genau das war
meine absicht meine lieben freunde also
nächste diese sache hier dingsbums
braucht man deiner meinung nach
markenklamotten um cool zu sein
nach meiner meinung nach also meiner
meinung nach braucht man das nicht aber
in unserer heutigen zeit wird es oft zu
angenommen dass ich meine stellt euch
mal vor ihr seht zwei leute auf der
straße und der eine hat echt coole
klamotten coolen style allgemein also
coolen style nicht über den coolen
marken klamotten sondern allgemeinen
coolen style der andere typ halt nicht
und das ist halt immer so das erste
mittlerweile was zählt und zwar das
aussehen das ist auch so bei mädels das
erste was eigentlich immer zählt ist das
aussehen das muss man wirklich zu sagen
weil wenn man eine frau ist zum beispiel
auf der straße sieht oder ein mädchen
sei in eurem alter
dann achtet man nicht zuerst darauf so
dies bestimmt total nett und total
sozial und geht total gut mit mit
kindern um und so weil das sieht man
nicht beim ersten mal
also beim ersten mal sehen jetzt nicht
beim ersten mal das jetzt gerade denkt
na ja auch ihre die höhe wo ich noch
eingehen wollte
und ja also
ich also meine persönliche meinung ist
natürlich nein braucht man nicht aber
erstens musste jeder seine eigene
meinung bilden
und zweitens mitläufer so ein bisschen
wie in der realen mitläufer hat das
eigentlich wenig zu tun aber da dass
viele leute so sagen und zu
interpretieren von wegen gerade trägt so
komische klamotten lässt bestimmt nicht
cool mit dem ich nichts zu tun haben
also ich finde man muss es nicht sein
und naja der toll tolles thema games
teil toll wie soll ich darüber jetzt
klatschen ist ein komisches video eines
liters muss schon sagen sollten
komisches lied so franke sprach über
frank laurich das ist traurig viele von
euch werden filmkritik denn kennen der
ist der wahl sage ich mal youtuber der
filme die im kino laufen trader
hochgeladen hat die bewertet hat wie das
wohl ankommen könnte im kino
der ist nämlich verstorben ich möchte
jetzt gar nicht er seine trauer stimmung
erzeugen weil ich denke das hätte er
nicht gewollt das will ich auch nicht
weil das jetzt eigentlich ein freudiges
let's play da will man so etwas nicht
machen
und ja also wti hat das gepostet weil er
das wirklich auf seiner seite hatte
nicht er sondern irgend jemand anderes
hat es wirklich auf seiner seite
gepostet dass er gestorben ist es ist
die rede von einer lungenkrankheit oder
so habe ich jetzt gehört aber ich kann
da nichts versprechen was daran jetzt
war es stimmt keine ahnung
das heißt google einfach mal ein
bisschen ich habe auch selber ip frank
ausgeschrieben weil er echt ein cooler
youtuber war muss man nicht zu sagen
und ja es traurig dass er jetzt halt von
uns gegangen ist aber ist ein thema
wobei ich eigentlich nicht so gerne
reden möchte
also ich hab keinen spitzhacke mehr
sagte ich ein tolles thema aber dass ich
auf jeden fall reden will real madrid
oder barcelona ich find barcelona viel
besser und viel sympathischer auf vor
allem weil ich auch messi besser finde
und ronaldo einfach nur
hasse das irgendwann skelett so herzlich
an sind dass ihr herz hat sich auch so
an als ob irgendeiner schwimmen würde
blödmann wartete er das schon und will
mich töten stimmt nicht ich will noch
eine weile auf ok was würde ich sagen
okay ich es doch was ach so nimmst du
bald mal spiele von konsole auf also
dass sich diego jetzt nicht darauf dass
josué und zwar habe ich da habe ich
letztens irgendwann ich brauche
irgendwie kohle habe ich letztens
irgendwann bei facebook gepostet ja ich
hoffe jetzt mal so eine elgato game
capture card um dann zu schauen ob ich
damit mal konsole aufnehmen kann weil
ich hab mir fifa bereits da natürlich
gekauft ich hier besser fifa fan auf
erden ich liebe dieses spiel einfach nur
ja stimmst du mir zune oder völlig ich
wollte nicht warten moment ich geb dir
was zu essen ich wollte ich einfach nur
nein noch nicht absetzen so dass dein
schwanz geht hoch geil jetzt bist fertig
so gut jetzt habe ich aber fast gar
nichts mehr
du arschloch zurück oder ich schlag dich
und da habe ich eigentlich gedacht dass
ich mal einfach fifa aufnehmen könnte
und mal schauen könnt ihr wieder bei
euch so ankommt ich habe ja schon auf
konstruktiver gemachter kampf sehr gut
an
also wollte thaller dass ich ein
bisschen mehr mache und da habe ich
einfach mal gedacht ja kommen kannst ja
mal hier die sonne game capture card
kaufen kostet jetzt ja auch nicht die
welt dieses ding und deswegen hab ich
mir gedacht ja kommt kannst eigentlich
noch machen will ich dazu mediamarkt
gefahr mit dem kumpel der zum glück
schon führerschein und auto hat aber mit
seiner hingestellt
ich hoffe war noch bei max ich weiß gar
nicht mehr
coleman sein kumpel hat der denn auto
hat das ist ganz cool
naja und dann waren wir da halt bei
mediamarkt ich trat also rein mit ihm
und dann haben sie hier die e game
capture card weil dort habe ich opfer
ihrer website da gesehen dass stand fast
so habe ich dann so gesagt und er so
warte ich guck mal okay ja da ist und
zeigt nämlich auch dann stand ich wieder
hin weiter so das ist nicht die exakte
game capture kazuyo ist aber eine
geldkarte zug ich würde aber gerne el
castillo vorschob wir haben diego
benaglio aber warum habt ihr die anderen
hier in webseiten er soll die website
die wird sehr selten geupdatet und ich
so etwas sehr schönes wetter heute im
internet also ich da nicht so tolles
extra mit ihm zum mediamarkt fahre bei
diesen spritpreisen heute nähe und dann
erfahren wir da das ist dort doch nicht
gibt weiß nicht ganz so toll aber gab es
nur so eine blöde game capture card wo
nicht mal hdmi hatte die nicht mit die
nicht nach ademi hatte wohl gehofft
bevor die hatte nicht mal hdmi also da
muss das denn wirklich so mit analoger
anschließen dann kannst du nicht mal
dazu live quatsch das heißt du könntest
nur ein 360 p gameplay aufnehmen und
nach kommentieren mandat wäre total wird
gewesen weil fifa da musste einfach so
reaktion ein fang und tore
und na ja das geht nicht nach
kommentieren übrigens nicht nur fifa
sondern menschen werden dann doch
irgendwie andere spiele kommen wie keine
ahnung trials wenn es draußen ist
es ist in spiel drei eventuell aber ich
weiß noch nicht ob ich mir die karte
wirklich kauf und ob ihr dafür seien
keine ahnung
so also ja wenn irgendwann werden auf
jeden fall konsolenspiele kommen
spätestens wenn ich 18 angeboten habe
ich mir dass alles so installieren dass
das alles hinkriegen
mittlerweile bin ich ja schon ich bin 17
ich bin doch gar nicht 16 16 17 naja so
gut wir aktualisieren zeit hier mal kurz
wieder auf cool macht zwar alleine alter
ist aber eine menge angekommen louis
krass okay marcel hess fragt bist du ein
heißer junge ich bin eigentlich ganz
froh waren also ich habe normale
körpertemperatur
nein ich weiß worauf das bezogen war
warum soll ich ein schweißband
freundlich man eigentlich eigentlich
kann es euch scheißegal sein wie ich
aussehe
was sie mache solange meine videos cool
findet und die feiert ist alles in
ordnung
eventuell werde ich mich irgendwann mal
zeigen eventuell irgendwann heißt nicht
jetzt morgen und übermorgen in zwei
monaten und keine ahnung dass suche ich
mir schon selber aus und ob es überhaupt
mache so wann wird der die erste gepusht
glaub das wird im konto qui einmal
gemacht der kontakt hat jetzt auch ein
eigenes intro von venedig erstellt dann
kann dich cooler typ und der erste die
erste wird sehr bald gepusht ich platze
mal die fackeln alle da oben ein
bisschen anders
also nicht dass ihr da irgendwie denkt
ich sage das nur und ihr könnt eure
kommentare schreiben und dann passiert
dann nachher nichts natürlich wird er
demnächst noch gepusht werden ordentlich
wieder gepusht werden und damit einfach
die kleinen let's play eine chance haben
welche allgemein mehr der typ bin der
ich sach mal sich so ein bisschen für
euch einsetzen weil ich selber einen
schwierigen start hatte auf youtube und
ich genau verstehen kann dass ihr
natürlich da möglichst große
aufmerksamkeit wollt
machen ihr was ich brauch erst mal so
eine komische wasserquelle und ich
glaube das fließt aber nicht soweit naja
also deswegen werden da ein paar gepusht
der kontakt er ihn noch nicht kennt
wollte ich eigentlich wöchentlich machen
schaffe ich allerdings nicht aufgrund
themen und so weiter das heißt ich mache
das einfach dann
sie hat mir fällt grad auf
nee oder her oder kann ich nicht ich
weiß es nicht ich glaub ich muss nachher
immer einen runter gehen oder westerwald
ich probiere es einfach mal
nee das geht halt noch ein hoch oder
hier an rolle eigentlich egal
ich probiere es einfach mal wie weit
fließt denn sondern wassereimer hier
es kann nämlich lassen dann packe ich da
noch welche dann fließt die hierhin und
lüftet oder wartet wie weit fließt jetzt
hier wenn ich einen rein packe 2 3 4 5 6
sind das okay ich weiß wie ich das mache
so also auf ein grad stehen geblieben
ach so ja beim putzen ja da das wird
kommen demnächst und vor allem dann auch
beim konter reise konto gezahlt dass ich
themen behandelte über die rede
meine meinung sage und eventuell noch
ein paar news zum einem kanal und
zweiter vermutlich und hält am ende in
einen kanal erwähne den ich pushe also
der der mir besonders gut gefällt den
ich euch empfehlen kann so das passt
perfekt
nächstes thema von leon play games erst
mal leon play games irgendwoher kommt
mit der name bekannt vorsicht ob du
schreibst dass bei kommentare das ganz
cool
ein paar leute merkt man sich einfach
mal die wirklich immer kommentare
schreiben
da kann ich jetzt mal ein paar leute
hier erwähnen die jetzt vielleicht gar
nicht damit rechnet dass ich überhaupt
kenne hier gibt's die gibt's d2 hd oder
irgendwie so daniel p gibt es gibt ja
ihren play games ist gibt erlahmt grad
gar nie ein
es gibt auf jeden fall leute die
schreiben echt richtig viel kommentare
was mich immer wieder freude zu sehen
dass er da wirklich auf sortis seit
freud nicht einfach nur keine ahnung
finde ich eigentlich irgendwie cool
einfach cool ist das so ja und zwar
meint der leon play games wie hat sich
youtube deiner meinung nach entwickelt
ich glaube dort werde ich den titel
schreiben und zwar kann ich darüber
jetzt erstmal den rest der folge
quatschen bzw
sondern zehn minuten vielleicht noch
youtube wie ihr wisst ist mittlerweile
einfach nur richtig kacke finde ich halo
klar warum sagst für youtube das café du
verdienst auch damit ein geld ja dass
ein mensch mit
ja das stimmt schon allerdings seien
allerdings ist youtube die verändern
wirklich jede woche mittlerweile
irgendwas die startseite ist
mittlerweile wieder anders und dabei
machen es einfach alles kaputt finde ich
youtube ist nicht mehr das was es einmal
war damals was einfach so komplett
startseite war anders war besser finde
ich sogar und der mittlerweile wirklich
alles einfach so wie so ein blog
aufgebaut also soll block also blg so
ist es mittlerweile aufgebaut so von
wegen facebook timeline so alles
untereinander neu sbt aktivitäten das
ist für mich nicht youtube der sollen
die videos nach und nach oben angezeigt
werden und nicht so wie bei facebook
hier den haupt meldungen oben und so
weiter und vor allem jetzt in letzter
zeit ist es ja bei youtube auch so dass
youtuber alle youtuber einfach die
abonnenten haben verlieren einfach so
abonnenten und kriegen nachher wie das
doppelte dazu das versteh nicht also bei
mir ist es so das hat ja schon bei
facebook gepostet das wirklich youtube
abriss kaputt macht das heißt bitte
einfach auf meinen kanal gehen aber noch
da ist oder wenn ihr dieses video seht
wird es wahrscheinlich da sein und zwar
löschte youtube ganz einfach abonnenten
warum die daten machen weil sie nicht
unter die löschen nicht in aktive
account sowie das möchte gesagt habe
sondern ich löschen noch aktive accounts
also ich hab da auch von leuten erfahren
die mich mit ihrem aktiven bekannte
abonniert haben und das abo war auf
einmal einfach weg obwohl sie mich nicht
die abonniert haben also die haben da
wirklich nichts gemacht und trotzdem
weit weg also ist eigentlich ganz
komisch
immer kurz überlegen da oben jetzt so
die wasser flüssig gemacht jetzt kommen
die hier noch einfließen die hier runter
denn dann falle die hier noch mal ganz
kurz runter also ich weiss ich mache die
monster falle total kompliziert und ihr
könnt das alle viel besser aber ich bin
halt mir ein komplizierter typ also hier
geht man auch noch mal ein bisschen
tiefer aber darum kümmern wir uns
nachher irgendwo müsste jetzt hoch war
dass da was da noch nicht da auch nicht
weil ich gehe zu allen seiten aus zu der
wo es war
na ja also ich finde youtube geht nicht
so eine gute richtung und allgemein dass
sie ziemlich was kaputt machen einen
hund als haustier oder doch lieber was
anderes ich komme nicht hoch die homos
was mich hier hoch danke ich find
kaninchen und meerschweinchen ganz cool
und die sind noch nicht so pflege schwer
wie ein hund also wenn schon mehr
scheint die kaninchen gegen die so etwas
in die richtung
find ich jetzt persönlich besser nico
kanitz thema kinderarbeit bronze was
will ich im letzten licht bereden das
sind so themen wirklich die die kanzel
politikern sagen mit welchen leuten aber
naja ich dachte wenn private auf einmal
warten baum
aber hauptsache dem uns geht's gut da
können wieder direkt hier nicht sagt
kann mir jetzt jetzt kommt zack zack
zack
und jetzt kommen bestimmt irgendwelche
skelette weil sie mich wohl noch 1000
meter entfernung gesehen haben
doch nicht schön so nächste frage mich
was halloween comic schöner name ich
noch nie gehört den neuen roaming ja
halloween ist ja am ende oktober/anfang
november also jetzt so beziehungsweise
jetzt nächstes wochenende sag ich mal
wir haben frei wegen allerheiligen unter
anderen und zwar nächste woche
donnerstag freitag donnerstag
allerheiligen wird glaube ich halloween
oder so auf jeden fall werde ich an
halloween und an den tagen danach
wahrscheinlich zu hause sein
beziehungsweise immer nur ab und zu weil
der echt eine menge wie geburtstage bzw
anderen machen halloween partys oder
irgendwie so da bin ich echt immer
irgendwo dazwischen jetzt bei halloween
erzähle ich könnte jetzt als mögliche
erzählungen weiß und zwar fast gar
nichts so kommt ihr der hund alltag
verpiss dich doch kommt es an ich schlag
dich jetzt bis wieder hier am roman komm
herein
er kommt mir ein arschloch karte draußen
sitzen bleiben hier passt auf gut ich
mache spitzhacke lava brauche ich
übrigens auch fällt mir auf nächstes mal
machen wir dann einfach mal eine
höhlentour bogen kann ich auch mal
machen habe ich eigentlich ein bogen ich
glaube ich absolut bohnen spitzhacken
erst mal ein schwert davon habe ich
nicht mehr so viel natur die tools von
natal die tour ist voll
ich muss mir eine neue tour machen und
alles voll mit steinen er ist auch
witzig so schön
wo kann ich jetzt in ställen hat den
ofen broich ähnlich schlechte dannecker
einfach naja neues thema was gibt es da
so die die hab ich ja alle schon mal
guckst du selber letzt player die habe
ich dann die beantwortet war eigentlich
fast gar nicht die einzige die ich gucke
sind space boxplay mittlerweile also
zurzeit weil die das echt interessant
gestalten aber sonst eigentlich niemand
wie gucke ich denn so und wohl keine
ahnung
da fällt mir ein
also so für schnelle keinen let's play
den ich irgendwie wirklich dauerhaft
gucke
natürlich dieser kontrast der sehr übel
scheiße also den kopier auf gar keinen
fall
weil sie so einen großen buchstaben noch
nie gesehen das ist wirklich so ein
großer bursche der es locker so groß es
ist einfach nur richtig krass dass sich
das überhaupt noch traut das zu machen
das finde ich ja heftig wenn wir den
ganzen leuten die den kassen ist sehr
richtig krass und immer das einfach
nicht verstehe ja auch nicht naja gibt
halt mal so blöde leute
naja so gut genug gelästert alter wie
viel wollen wir auch schon haben geht er
richtig schnell
so wackeln kann ich auch mal wieder
machen wo sind die ganzen sticks darin
noch bestimmte und zu guter letzt worauf
wir alle gewartet habt ich soll das mal
machen jetzt hier mit denen mit den sieg
und zwar so ein paar mal mit der hohe
darauf geklappt allerdings meinten da
wieder leute in den kommentaren
hey du darfst dich so schnell aufgeben
du musst das follow-up machen
okay machen wir das jetzt mal voll oft
gute rechtsklick angeblich auf die
grasfläche dann kommt das dach aus
linksklick fördert verstehe ich nicht
was soll ich machen linksklick auf
dingens
und da passiert einfach nichts
vielleicht besser abbauen
obwohl achter nicht abhauen einfach nur
rechtsweg aktuell
danke an alle die es wirklich immer von
tränen ich das nicht hier geglaubt habt
danke jetzt hab ich hier endlich sieht
das schön ist was raus kommt endlich so
viel war jetzt elf in hatte das reicht
ich kann jetzt wieder oben bringen ihren
einbringen kann ja auch einfach hier
eine rolle gehen wolle
so was gibt's da sonst noch ein bisschen
hoch was hältst du von castingshows wo
also da gibt es ganz verschiedene was in
england oder so dieses x-factor heißt
das dort glaube ich glaube ich auf dem
deutschland x-factor war das in amerika
oder england oder canal das ist finde
ich sehr viel geiler weil die deutschen
castingshows einfach alle kein niveau
haben aus als ob germany das ist echt
dass all die einzige castingshow jeder
noch ein bisschen niveau besitzt und
nicht einfach nur total verblödet ist
also meine meinung zu castingshows
eigentlich relativ negativ wenn sie wenn
es auf deutsche gezogen ist auf deutsche
castingshow wir können es aber ganz kurz
eine kleine farben anlegen damit ich mal
ganz kurz
sie sehen kann wie ich das ungefähr so
aufbauen kann seine farm so die farben
wollte ich übrigens in unserem raum
machen das heißt wir können die wand
hier eigentlich hier geht dann so eine
tür durch hier ist ein extrem karriere
neben abbauen also wie ich mir das
vorgestellt habe ich war jetzt auch
eigentlich schon längst ein
aufnahmestopp machen weil die folge
heute nicht ganz so lange gehen sollte
der kanadier durchgehend satt werden
nachher als ab gefällt und dann ist
quasi hier um so auch stein einfach nur
damit nicht anfällig für verbrennungen
und so weiter ist und dann mache ich
hier' sonnenfeld also ich mach dann
irgendwie hier so
das wasser zack zack zack zack zack so
da mache ich hier natürlich erde so
jetzt hier die erde hilft da mache ich
jetzt mit der hof einmal drauf und jetzt
mit den sitz einfach so und jetzt
wachsen die so und das wäre ich jetzt
noch mal auf der seite und dann habe ich
ja schon die farm fertig selbst hier
auch nochmal so und dann wird darum dann
diese stein dingens kommen ich habe mir
darüber nicht sehr viel gedanken gemacht
haben von ungefähren planen wie es
aussehen könnte wenn wir natürlich wir
an ich hab das sieht übrigens die gerade
ich sehr rechts einen kommentar der gut
aufgelegte die witzigsten hater
nachrichten nachrichten die du je
bekommen hat kann ich nicht zu viel
sagen weil ich eigentlich nicht so viel
härter nachrichten bekommen also hater
allgemein traurige nachricht zu
schreiben die schreiben eigentlich immer
nur kommentare und blockieren einer ganz
schnell damit man ihn nicht antworten
kann oder irgendwie so keine ahnung ich
weiß nicht was in ihren köpfen los ist
aber irgendwie ist das relativ peinlich
finde ich sagen egal hätten alleine
bringt nicht viel weil dadurch bekommen
wir youtuber nur aufrufe und nicht immer
zeigen die nicht also ich glaube ich
kommt erst gar nicht ein
naja ich kann aber trotzdem bisschen
darüber quatschen und zwar nehmen wir
dabei ein paar kumpels stones texte und
kann das direkt herum bauen und zwar an
letztens ein ganz wichtiger kommentar
hey du bist vor der spaß der du kannst
dich mal bauen diese gucken sich die
ganzen leute beim let's play kommt es
nicht auf solche ich beantworte das
jetzt mal normal hier beim display kommt
es nicht aufbauen an meine freunde beim
let's play kommt das auf den letztlich
und seine stimme an und nicht darauf wie
toll er hinten gebäude baut also das
müsste da müssen manche leute echt mal
differenzieren können was denn da jetzt
hier so die grenze ist seit mal dass
erst jetzt 73
und er meinte dann echt so ja eh du bist
voll kacke weil du kannst nicht bauen
ich weiß ich kann nicht bauen das sage
ich in jeder folge wird mittlerweile
fast damit nicht immer welche ankommen
zu sagen hey du kannst ja überhaupt
nicht bauen
und es kommen noch welche an also mir
ist es relativ egal ich will nicht
unbedingt bauen können ich habe ich
brauche das eigentlich nicht neu ok cool
ich drück einfach gar nichts ok ich
drücke einfach nix ich kann die
klatschen und ich laufe einfach weiter
hier ich klatsch hier schön super freut
mich jetzt muss weg cool hatte ich schon
mal ein t3 c war das glaube ich
wie fällt cutoff ich hab schon wieder
sehr langgezogen wir sind schon wieder
über 40 minuten mein gott ich wollte
endlich mal wieder eine folge unter 40
minuten machen
ich glaube mittlerweile alles das was
ich irgendwann hatte ich aber zwei
wochen pause mit lustig das haben wir
schon längst wieder eingeholt
weil hier echt wenn ihr nur um aufnehmen
los der bisher krieg echt kontinuierlich
immer videos ist ganz cool
naja gut also so schnell dass ungefähr
fordern so das haus nachher ich weiß es
sieht nicht schön aus ich weiß ich kann
nicht bauen schreibt mir ruhig in die
kommentare
los schreibt mir die kommentare spricht
mit der hand 8 keine ahnung was ich
wieder von mir gebe na ja gut ich würde
sagen das war's erst mal von lost ich
habe mir jetzt mal diese runde gemacht
hatte ich letztes mal kurz den postweg
an jemanden machen
alter ist echt krass viele kommentare
sorgen löschen sagt gelöscht so wenn ihr
das nächste mal in der luft folge dabei
sein wollt namentlich erwähnt werden
wollt oder nicht keine ahnung
bei der nächsten aufnahme irgendwie
nächste woche freitag oder so post ich
wieder bei facebook einfach irgendwann
poste ich da kann auch schon donnerstag
sein
hey leute ich nehme jetzt lust auf
schreibt mit themen in die kommentare
so nach dem motto und dann können wir
halt einfach themen in die kommentare
schreiben
dann würde ich einfach mal sagen es wird
nacht das ist jetzt mal ganz toll
richtig super ist das weil ich da jetzt
gerade halb offen stehende fand ihr habt
und da jetzt eben doch dann pennen muss
weil ich brauche es mal so provisorisch
irgendwie zu so also wenn ihr das
nächste mal dabei sein wollt bei lost
während ich hier kommentiere und zocke
und einfach mal ein paar fragen stellen
wollte das so einfach bei facebook
vorbeigucken da sitzt unser hund schöne
und braver hund brava und brav bist du
da bist du niedlich oder hättest und
schaaf zu schaffen die hole ich mir in
der nächsten folge so gut
bis zum nächsten mal wie immer wenn euch
das video gefallen hat gebt ihm wieder
einen daumen hoch also wenn es gut und
wenn jetzt nicht so gut fanden dann gebt
dem video einen daumen runter diese
dreht den bildschirm um und gibt mir
einen traum runter oder keine ahnung ich
weiß nicht ist egal
wieso sind dass ihr wieder abgetrocknet
dass kein auge zumachen so jörn wirklich
sterben sehen wir uns in einer woche
wieder wenn es wieder heißt hallo meine
lieben freunde und herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen folge lässt also tschüss